hey Mary here with another gamespot news
update the former creative director of
the incharge of series Amy Hennig is
joining forces with EA studio visceral
games to bring us nathan drake in space
oh it's a star wars game following the
announcement by EA any took to Twitter
to explain her move very excited to
share that i'm joining visceral games as
creative director on the new Star Wars
project it's a privilege to have the
opportunity to contribute to the Star
Wars universe after its had such a
formative influence on my life two
amazing things entered my life in 1977
star wars and the Atari 2600 this
opportunity is the confluence of the two
most influential experiences of my youth
I couldn't be more excited to go on this
journey panic began her career in games
at EA and 1991 where she worked as a
game designer artist on several projects
including Michael Jordan in the Windy
City more recently she worked at Naughty
Dog at the creative director of the
Uncharted series she was the lead writer
of the upcoming charted for for
PlayStation 4 but left the studio early
last month Visceral Games is officially
working on a new game set in the Star
Wars universe the game is rumored to the
open world although EA has not provided
any official details so what do you guys
think is Amy the chosen one to bring
balance to the Star Wars universe
comment below and be sure to check out
gamespot com for all the latest in EA
news